so I've got a really fun announcement to
make can I get a drumroll or something i
am going to the MTV Video Music Awards
okay you can stop the drumline I'm going
to be hosting several Twitter segments
during the pre-show now what's that even
mean that means I'm gonna be sitting
around watching all of the tweets come
in about the vmas analyzing them
watching them and somehow making sense
of what all of you guys are tweeting
about and portraying that onto your
television so be sure to tune in this
sunday September 13th the mtv vmas or
make sure you're watching the pre-show
and you are tweeting your little fingers
off about everything that's going on
because not only will I be reading them
I just may or may not read it right
there on live television for you in
addition to being on your TV on Sunday
night which I hope that you'll watch I'm
also to be posting tons of clips on both
of my youtube channels and some fun
stuff on mtv.com from various events
that i go to celebrities that i may or
may not run into and well any other kind
of craziness that i might get into and
the best part about all of this is I'm
taking you guys with me on this
adventure so feel free to tweet me all
week and yes I do actually reply to
almost all of my Twitter's but tweet the
most on Sunday because that's what I'm
actually looking for good tweets to read
on TV if you want any more information
check out my blog at iJustine com or
check out VMA to MTV com for all of the
details this is completely relevant to
this entire video I have an extra iphone
charger here and I don't really know
what to do with it this is a really a
contest but all you got to do is write
this video five stars and leave me a
comment saying what you guys would like
to
mediaeval New York I'll just pick
somebody at random and get yourself a
nice new little purple iphone treasure
oh and don't forget to click Subscribe
to love ya
you